hoy les quiero invitar a que me escuchen
desde el amor desde su corazón
los invito a que sean esos un segundito
en su corazón
y estable
qué es el amor
que estaba usted está el amor que dicen
en un ejemplo como lo viene hoy
bien
[Aplausos]
veo que muchos de ustedes dicen que el
hambre es un sentimiento de emoción
sus ejemplos creo que es estar con el
máquina con mi novio con mi esposo con
mi esposa con mis hijos
sal
a mí este tema también me confundió
muchísimo fuiste tú si existe el amor si
está con mi familia con mi novio con mis
amigos pero creo que el amor o mucho más
allá de eso esos lazos son uniones son
acuerdos
el amor no tiene límites el amor es el
amor es todo es nuestra naturaleza
pero no
es un truco de amor
si me acuerdo que va a servir muchísimo
pues los invito a escuchar a los niños
los verdaderos expertos del amor los
niños no se detienen en pensar cuando
les pregunto y eso es luz son amor son
expansión
el nivel es igual
creen que necesitamos
bueno los invito por sus ojos
y los invito a pensar
qué te dices a ti mismo que no puedes
hacer hoy
si no miras límites
el universo está dentro de ti qué triste
es tu a ti mismo
ok
bueno eh les platico
yo veo yo que digo en mí misma que soy
muy mala con la tecnología
he hecho esta presentación
les invito a que todas esas cosas que se
digan que se dicen a ustedes mismos que
no pueden hacer las carteles la ropa
saben lo que pueden hacer con eso vamos
a transformar todos esos pensamientos
negativos en algo positivo en luz en
amor los invito para que cuando lleguen
a citada ronda de esta hoja y siempre
hay una semilla la semilla de frijol un
tulipán la que quiera vamos a
transformar todos esos pensamientos
negativos
si puedes
si el universo entero estuviera dentro
de ustedes
que desearían realmente qué es lo que
desean sin juicio hombre tienen un
millón de euros que en una casa en la
que digan lo que como si se les para
cumplir ahorita ya no quiere ser
por qué
ahora donde se transforman los positivo
como si ya lo tuvieran
hoy aquí y ahora
si ya tengo mi casa y la riviera en
vende
que creen que yo es lo que quiero hoy
que ya soy
yo soy
amor incondicional
en un ejercicio consciente con la
persona que tienen al lado
positivo
tradicional
[Música]
ahora la persona
el dinero
y que sintieron
el concepto
por qué no vamos todo regalando amor no
puede estar nada y la vida se pone mejor
ok
ahora aquí y ahora lista de olivo para
búsqueda la cual es sencilla tiene
visión de estas vidas
ah
ok
compensando así el color favorito
en su cuerpo donde piel
ya todos tenemos
bueno les voy a hablar muy importante
esta es esencia
entonces miren
muy bien
por mis por mis clientes
d
sí
ok
soy yo
después el primer super poder
azul turquesa
superpoder mi sensibilidad
se dan cuenta como todos tenemos ese
alma
ok y ahora los voy a hacer pensar un
poquito qué pasa cuando los siete
colores se unen
cuál es la unión de los siete colores
[Música]
willis
blanco
de dónde a dónde va
el sol
es la misma para todos
gotas al mar uniéndose a la bola en
reventar
hoy te invito a quererte tu brillo desde
tu alma es de tu incondicionalidad
te atrevas a hacer una gotita de amor
sabes que le podría salvar a alguien a
ti
esta unión esta luz de nuestros hermanos
se llaman turismo amor incondicional
igual
[Aplausos]